[MUSIC PLAYING]
Behold, I bring you tidings of great joy,
which shall be to all people.
For onto you is born this day in the city of David, a Savior
Jesus Christ the Lord and this should be a sign on to you.
Linus is right.
I won't let all this commercialism
ruin my Christmas.
I'll take this little tree home, and decorate it,
and I'll show them it really will work in our play.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
First prize.
Oh, well, this commercial dog is not going to ruin my Christmas.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
I've killed it.
Oh, everything I touch gets ruined.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
I never thought it was such a bad little tree.
It's not bad at all really.
Maybe it just needs a little love.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Charlie Brown is a blockhead, but he did get a nice tree.